[Music]
on september 6th the ukrainian army
launched an attack on the town of
balakuliya it had been held by the
russian army for more than six months
but by september 8th the ukrainian army
had recaptured it and they were just
getting started
over the next few days ukrainian forces
swept through this russian health
territory with astounding speed
ukrainian forces have blitzed through
russia's gains in a lightning
counter-offensive forcing russian forces
to retreat
as of september 14th ukraine claims it
recaptured nearly 8 000 square
kilometers of russian-held territory and
liberated dozens of towns it's a major
breakthrough for ukraine and it marks a
new phase in the war
so
how did ukraine pull off such a stunning
attack and how does it change the war
it's useful to think of the war in
ukraine as having three main phases so
far the first began when russia invaded
in february 2022 the russian military
swept into ukraine through the north
east and south and immediately clashed
with the ukrainian army this phase was
essentially the russians attempting to
force the ukrainian government to
surrender this is mason clark a russia
analyst at the institute for the study
of war an american think tank ukrainian
forces at the time
were in large part outgunned the most
intense fighting took place in a few
major cities like harkiv mariupol kirsan
and outside the capital kiev but by
april a few weeks into the war russia
had failed to capture kiev or harkiv it
did control a large swath of territory
though and continued to fight the
ukrainian army on three main fronts in
the northeast in the east and in the
south where it did control curson
that's when the second phase began
from about april to august this map
changed very little
russia for the most part stopped
conducting large sweeping attacks and
instead relied on its artillery pound
ukrainian positions but the russian army
was in bad shape the us government
estimates that as many as 80 000 russian
soldiers have been killed or wounded it
was very very devastating for them
particularly since the losses they were
taking early in the war were in the the
best of the russian military the easy
comparison is by this summer the
russians had lost more men than the
soviets did in nearly a decade of the
war in afghanistan
so during the summer russia used the
time to recruit more soldiers
but it didn't go well a fascinating
element of this is that the kremlin
still is calling this a special military
operation it cannot be referred to as a
war that actually matters because the
russians haven't called up conscripts
for this invasion and instead they're
trying to fill these gaps with these
various ad hoc methods the russians have
had to hire more mercenaries and offer
payments to prisoners they've even
raised the age limit to allow men over
40 to join the army and russia sent many
of these men with little training to the
front lines so it's led to a steady drop
off in the quality of russian personnel
throughout the war but while russia
struggled to rebuild its army ukraine
had the opposite problem there was
actually a sort of a bottleneck in may
where they had too many recruits and not
enough instructors to train them which
is
a very good problem to have with the
help from its western allies ukraine was
able to quickly train lots of these men
before sending them to the front this
really helped the ukrainian military not
just
produce more soldiers but very effective
soldiers better than the russians by the
end of august they were ready for the
next phase of the war their own attack
throughout the summer ukrainian leaders
talked a lot about their plans to launch
an attack and they made it pretty clear
that they would strike here curson key
to control of the south
ukraine moved many of its troops into
position near the city and used their
most advanced artillery to hit the
russians for weeks they were forcing the
undermanned russian army to make a
choice they had to pick somewhere to
send forces and they picked kirsan when
the russians moved troops to curson they
left the northeast vulnerable since it
was mostly guarded by those
inexperienced soldiers
so when ukraine did start their attack
in early september they didn't hit much
resistance there
[Music]
almost as soon as ukraine's soldiers
began the attack the russian forces
began to flee
these are piles of weapons and
ammunition left behind by russian troops
near harkiv they also left trucks tanks
and artillery behind and this is a
russian tank crew frantically fleeing
before crashing into a tree the russians
were running away and withdrawing faster
than the ukrainians were keeping up with
them while the russians retreated
ukraine took over all this territory
which included some important towns
izum was a russian supply dump and
kubiansk was a crucial railway hub
useful for moving troops and supplies
they've also freed thousands of
ukrainian civilians that have been
trapped under russian occupation for
months i think this was a very well done
opportunistic attack that went just
incredibly well for the ukrainian
military
meanwhile ukraine is still attacking her
son and making some progress but the
attack in harkev has begun a third phase
in the war where ukraine this time has
the momentum there's a long road ahead
the russians are going to try and
replace uh these further catastrophic
losses with likely diminishing returns
but i am confident in saying that the
shu is more on the other foot now with
ukrainian forces having the initiative
of choosing where the next major battle
of the war will occur and they have
clearly demonstrated that they can and
fully intend to take this war into 2023
and drive out the occupying russian
forces
[Music]
you